hello everyone and welcome to the other
match of the gold money asian rapid
knockouts
we're still in the semi-finals it's
magnus carlsen versus levon arunan and
in that previous match we've seen that
dinglurian was the victor of the first
day and artemia will have to do a little
bit better on the second one
but here we have a very exciting game uh
so the the match started off uh very
interestingly uh first lavon one
one in game one then magnus retaliated
in game two game three ended in
a draw and now this is game four so uh
if it's a draw then we go
on equal turns on the second day and if
either of them wins then of course he
wins uh the
the first match and uh as the title
suggests the day marks
10 years as magnus has been a number one
undefeated rating list
and uh for those of you who are maybe
interested uh i dug out
this rating list so this is 10 years and
one month ago
uh uh to give you an idea what the
what the chess world looked like before
magnus became world number one so this
is
uh from may 2011 so 10 10 years and one
month ago
it was vishwanathan anand who was uh
number one he was the highest rated with
an elo rating of 2817
followed by magnus carlsen with 2815 and
levon arunan with 2808 so as you can see
two of them still clashing it out today
and 10 years ago
uh they were they were well basically at
the top of the chess world
followed by vladimir kramnik vastly when
those were the top ten uh end to the top
twenty ruslav ponomariov alexander
grishok timur rajab
uh petersville nikita vithugov boris
girlfriend dimitria kovenko
so those were the top 20 you can see
that some of the
players who are in the uh in the top
today like
dingling or fabiano corona are not even
on the list so
there's no one each geary on the list so
it was uh very very
uh different times back then uh but just
wanted to show this to you guys uh you
know but but still magnus and levon
still
at the top flashing it out like you know
like like mad men
uh so uh let's check it out as this is a
game for whoever wins is the winner of
the first day so magnus with the white
pieces
opens with d4 we have knight to f6 and
magnus goes for bishop to f4
uh maybe trying to get some sort of a
london system going on we have d5
and now e3 uh we have bishop to g4 now
attacking magnus's queen
and f3 now we have bishop back to d7
and the g4 so magnets really uh going
with a
uh well with a very interesting setup
uh we have c5 by levon and now c3
uh and now there is one game where
knight to c6 was played it was played in
the men's uh team championship in russia
in 2016 between gatakomsky and ernesto
but here we have queen to b6 balavon
attacking the b2 pawn
and it is now already as of move six
that we have a completely new game so
let's see uh what happens magnus offers
a queen trait queen to b3
and it's often when you will have queens
on b6 and then b3 that neither player
wants to capture because if white
captures then black
black gets the same open a file and of
course if black captures then white gets
the same
open a file for the rook and neither
player wants to allow this so they both
just continue
like the queens aren't facing each other
e6 we have knight to d2
just continuing development we have c
for now trying to force this capture but
now magnus just goes back queen to c2
you have to keep defending your b2 pawn
uh bishop to d6 offering a trade of dark
square bishops and
magnus grabs this one uh we have bishop
captures queen captures and
now e4 threatening e5 to win material
so queen back to c7 by lavon and now e5
we have knight to g8 and now at knight
to e2 so just nicely continuing
development
uh but for the moment it's a very very
close position as you can see those
pawns
have not been exchanged not a single one
so knight to c6 and we have
f4 by magnus we have h5 now uh 11
offers this uh this pawn to open up the
the h5 for his rook
and now it's it's a question whether the
king will go queen so whether the king
is going to stay in the center of the
board but you have to react to this so
magnus grabs it
we have g captures rook captures and now
rook to g1
attacking the g7 pawn and now
levon doesn't want to go for anything
too crazy as you know you really don't
want to lose these games you
you don't want to draw this or maybe
somehow win it so
he doesn't want to sacrifice the pawn he
goes king to f8 nicely defends the pawn
and he says okay what do you do here so
magnus just continues knight to f3 maybe
we can shift the knight over to g5 we
have knight
g to e7 now this knight might be going
to f5
knight to g3 attacking the rook and rook
to h6 now we have queen to d2
and now comes b5 so very very confident
in his position and his king
being on f8 we have a3 by magnus and
a5 now we have h4 by magnus and
now comes uh f5 and levin uh said
in an interview after the game that he
this f5 mode did it was just a stupid
idea and
the there was no need uh you know uh for
playing such a move
uh but okay bishop to e2 we have knights
to d8
and now comes king to f2 we have a4
closing the position here on the queen
side so now as you can see there are no
breakthroughs on the queen side there is
no breakthrough
on in the middle of the board only only
place where a breakthrough can happen is
on the king's side
so here rook the g2 magnus takes this
into consideration and now he's gonna
double up here and try to do some damage
along the g
file knight to f7 uh we have rook eight
to g1
and now rook to h8 uh
trying to well just get maybe behind
behind of the pawn
uh trying to defend it also maybe you
can just free up your uh h6 square for
the night maybe bring the knight to g4
so you have to play something and here i
know uh some of you guys would just want
to you know sacrifice stuff but it's
still too early and if you go knight
captures an f5 with the idea of opening
up the attack here
knight captures actually defends the g7
pawn so that's out of the question
so instead we have h5 by magnus he just
continues advancing and now
knight to h6 we have knight to g5 now
you have to be careful if this bishop
moves you're gonna
lose a queen here so rook to a6 to help
out with the defense of the
uh sixth rank here and now knight to f1
now this knight will be shifted over to
uh to the e3 squared then the bishop is
coming to f3 and then maybe we can do
some damage this way
uh so here we have bishop to e8 uh and
now comes knight to e3 as planned we
have knight eat the g8
uh and the bishop to f3 now uh piling up
on this pawn here so at some point you
you might even just capture here and you
know just
get those pawns moving forward we have
queen to e7
and now uh magnus doesn't do anything
like that you could capture this you
could play this and then you get
two two connected past pawns in the
center of the board like this is
playable
and with little time on the clock it
might even be enough but magnus doesn't
want to rush he first
wants to bring his king to safety
there's no reason to open up the
position in such an aggressive way while
the king is on f2
so first magnus will shift his king all
the way to the queen side and this is
something that we often see
in top tier games where you know even in
the heat of the battle you can just
realize that nothing is really happening
until you decide it's happening
and you can take all the time in the
world shifting your king
to where it's safe so this is what
magnus does king to e1
bishop to f7 now king to d1 uh we have
rook to a7 by levon
now king the c1 we rook to d7 and now
magnus no longer wants to waste moves on
king b1 and king a2 as that
can always be played but he takes
advantage of the rook's odd position
on d7 and plays knight captures on d5
now the point is if you capture with the
pawn we
can just play e6 and the white just wins
this position
uh point is if you capture we're gonna
play rook to e2 uh with the double
attack on the bishop and once you defend
rook g to e1 there's a triple attack now
this is
impossible to defend so instead after
knight captures on e5 we have rook
captures uh
and now not going for bishop captures
but first knight captures on f7 so
clearing
everything for that rook captures and g7
move we have knight captures on f7
uh and now uh bishop characters on on d5
we have pawn captures and the now rook
captures on g7 so magnus did make a
breakthrough here but he did sacrifice
some material
uh to achieve this so will it be enough
uh we have knight
g to h6 by levon and now queen to g2
tripling up on the g file we have knight
to g for
closing of the g file but magnus says
nope that's that's not happening
uh just a rook captures on g4 he gives
back some of the material
but now cactus and captures and now
magnus is down a whole night
but he does have two connected past
pawns here he has a past h
pawn and his position is just much
better so can levon defend this we have
king to e8
now comes f5 controlling all of these
squares here well not that one obviously
uh and now levon says all right i can't
really just wait and do nothing
because that's exactly what i can do i'm
gonna give back the knight for two pawns
and try to defend this way
it's only one pawn so maybe it can be
done we have d captures queen captures
and now
we have this position where magnus is
only up upon but his position is very
impressive however
he has to play something like queen to
g6 check and then after let's say king
to the eighth queen to b6 check
then we can uh shift to the rook uh
maybe into the okay not here but maybe
via the g6 square for example king d7
we're going to play king to b1
hide our king all the way to a2 and then
bring our rook into the game
and hopefully chuck made the black king
if queen captures an f5 now our king is
completely safe here
and nothing can reach it and now we can
just you know continue
uh checking the black king capturing
these pawns it's uh
completely winning for white however
magnus played f6 here
it's a very tricky move he's threatening
queen to c8 to check to pick up the rook
also this pawn is now very very
dangerous
and he's hoping for queen captures uh
here but of course lavon is not
not about to do that levon plays a queen
to e3 with
check and now he finds a very sneaky way
of uh just trading queens
so that can't really be avoided we have
king to b1
and now queen to e4 with check and now
magnus has to play this position
queen captures pawn captures and now
rook to h1 and here
even though he's up upon it's a rook and
pawn end game and it's uh
it's a dead draw it'd be uh maybe a
better
try to go rook here to defend the pawn
and attack the b5 pawn since the b5 pawn
can't be defended
but they were extremely low both on time
so the point is after king f7 we're
gonna capture here and after you capture
here
then we start bringing our king into the
game and this is nicely protected we're
gonna bring the king here
and we white retains some winning
chances
but he tried rook to h1 and now levon
has a very clear way of of doing things
king to f7
we have h6 king captures on f6 and now
king to c1 and now there is only one
move that allows lavon to not lose the
game
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this equalizing move
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on staying true
uh to the end game and you know
mastering it uh and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's a rook
to d8 we have to cut off the white king
from entering the game and that's all
that's needed
to draw this uh point is now h7 can
always be met with king to g7 and there
will be no way for white to make
progress
uh magnus tried rook to d1 he of course
would like to
very much trade uh for those of you who
do not believe me
i i mean it's completely winning because
you have the outside pass pawn and after
black goes after it we're just gonna
pick up this pawn
and then after the king starts
retreating uh we're much faster and
we're just gonna gobble up all of these
pawns and
that's it just win the game easily so
instead we have rooked the d3 by the one
saying okay we can trade but then i get
a
nicely defended pass pawn here on d3 so
magnus goes back rook to h1 but now
rook back to d8 we have h7 and now of
course not allowing h8 queen
king to g7 we have looked at h5
now going after the b5 pawn uh and here
uh levon said all right
you you have your fun with my pawns here
on the queen side i'm just going to put
a rook behind my pass pawn and you know
just win the game
but this is uh this is a big mistake by
levon the thing is
uh that rook on d8 is preventing the
king from entering the game and you have
to start pushing right away and that's
the way to to not lose the game
however 11 played uh rook to e8 and now
uh
now it's a problem because now magnus
gets king to d2 in
we have e3 check king to e2 and now
instead of having a king on c1 that does
nothing he has a king on e2 that
basically
covers everything so uh what can levon
do here he plays king to h8
but now rook captures on b5 you can't
really stop this with king captures on
h7
rook the b for now uh we are king to g6
now rook captures on c4 levon spawns are
just disappearing from the board we have
rook to a8
now king captures an e3 and now we all
know that
being one up uh being up one pawn isn't
uh
you know everything but being up two
pawns uh well that's just that's just
game so king to if i was
played king d3 with king to e5 now come
to rook to b4
we have king to d5 now comes c4 check
king to c6 and now king to c3 we rook to
a5 but now
rook to b5 magnus is even showing off a
little bit here
saying that even if he gives back one
pawn it's still completely winning
because we can just uh you know
uh uh take away all the important
squares from the black king he will have
to move we're gonna take away more
important squares and then after we get
to b4 we're gonna pick up the pawn
and of course king and two pawns is
always stronger than the king
so after rook b5 we have rooked a7 by
levon but now
king to b4 and now there's not much to
be done rook 8 was played rook to a5
going after the pawn
rook beat check king to c3 and he was in
this position on move 66
that magnus that levon aryan resigned
the game and uh well
uh what a wonderful victory for magnus
carlsen who by winning game four of the
match uh wins
uh the the the the entire first match so
levon will have to win the second match
tomorrow if he wants to force tie breaks
for a chance to
you know get get his spot in the finals
to face either ding or artemyev
magnus is still doing great as you can
see uh 10 years of
being number one we'll see how long he
can
continue pushing it and well how long he
can continue
winning winning events like this
uh so here you resign because after you
make one more move let's say rugby three
check we're gonna move in there's no
defending this the the pawn is gonna
fall whatever you do
we're just gonna capture it and that's
it once the rook moves we have three
pawns black has zero
this of course completely winning so
after king to c3 levon resigned and
magnus wins match one
uh so there we have it hope you guys
enjoyed it uh if you guys uh
want it uh here it is one more time so
you can you know just enjoy it
this this was the top 20 uh 10 years and
one month ago before magnus overtook
vishwanathan and became the world number
one
uh so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed that as well i would like to
thank leandra morrison constantino buchi
vladolaro
and melanie peters for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day